so not only dumb and totally ignorant of
everything but utterly self-assured if
there were a clinical exam for
self-esteem she'd be in the hundredth
percentile how do people get like that
is it our education system is it high
schools is it colleges we wanted to talk
to someone on the front lines of this
who might know the answer
Nikolas Giordano is a professor of
political science at Suffolk Community
College and he joins us tonight
professor thanks very much for coming on
all right so there's a certain
recognizable syndrome here where the
people who know the least are the most
self-confident where does that come from
well it's the it's the lack of critical
thinking that exists it's the
superficial arguments they make that are
completely unrealistic if you look at
the green New Deal it's incomprehensible
and when you're looking at it she says
the world is gonna end in 12 years so if
we go with this plan and have to rebuild
every building it took us 13 years just
to build the Freedom Tower
for instance six years to build the
Tappan Zee Bridge imagine having to do
every single building in the United
States up to new codes it's just not
gonna work and it's that they they don't
ask deep questions the arguments are it
sounds good
people will support it because it's
government giving us stuff and so it's
okay but there are real consequences
when you actually talk like this because
there are people that are gonna take it
seriously you have a number of
presidential candidates that have agreed
with her plan and when you're looking at
the plan itself you can't understand
anything in it it would lead to millions
of people being underemployed or
unemployed maybe they could learn code
who knows it would lead to
unconstitutional state violations
because state and local governments are
in charge of building codes and so my
question of her would be has she read
the Constitution knows about the Tenth
Amendment and state right but you heard
wait but I think that's a fundamental
misunderstanding you heard her say what
matters is that she's a really good
person and you're not and so I'm
thinking as I'm watching this remember
that whole fad we were supposed to give
our kids self-esteem and that was the
panacea did we create people like this
when we did that what we did too
the motto of the customer is always
right
created an entitlement culture and then
our children are precious also created
the entitlement approach culture where
everyone gets the trophy when you're
looking at it and you're trying to
challenge the minds of the youth they
try and push back because they don't
want to critically analyze the
information to see if it really works
page 10 of her new deal talks about
creating public ownership and receiving
a percentage of compensation for the
public ownership
well that's socialism that's the very
definition of socialism and nobody's
called her out on it in this sense and
it didn't work out so well for Venezuela
so is it really gonna work out well for
us
no no not I mean I don't know it's been
great for I guess weight loss in
Venezuela they're starving they are like
that you can zoo animals and that's part
of a problem it's there there's no
critical thinking and not only do you
have that part you have even more
concerning it talks about persons of the
United States
it doesn't say US citizens or US persons
which is a definition of citizen and
legal resident you're right so that
raises the question anyway anyone who
shows up gets to take your stuff and you
can see where this is going
professor at a time unfortunately I I
commend you for having the patience to
try and train a more impressive next
generation of critical thinkers thank
you for that no problem